there was a guy who actually says a
couple of weeks ago who on Twitter was
telling me oh yeah I work for the firm
that you know moms demand hires whenever
they have events and I've had moms
demand and Everytown confirm this to me
separately from this but you're hiring
private security for you but you don't
want other individuals to have that
access I don't want to outsource the
carrying of my firearm and that seems
really classist if we're to have a
discussion about legitimate class
warfare I would think the idea that only
people wealthy enough to hire private
security to protect them that is
incredibly classist because not
everybody has Bloomberg money not
everybody is in that position
[Music]
you've probably loved the fact that I
haven't really brought up guns with the
gun lady but let's let's do a little bit
let's do a little bit on guns I'm sure
I'm not the first person to refer you as
the gun lady right that's the gun lady
it seems like they probably have
different adjectives before gun lady
there's probably some other adjectives
they put in there also is
interchangeable
Touche Touche okay so we actually don't
have to do a ton on it because you do so
much time you spend so much time talking
about this stuff but could you could we
do like two or three things that you
would love to explain to say anti-gun
people or two or three things that are
like the memes that are just
misunderstood about our laws or about
the Second Amendment just a couple
things that we could maybe clean up
because I think you've had to spend a
lot of time doing that sort of thing
there was that infamous CNN Town Hall
after Parkland and and that was just an
absolute fiasco but maybe just a couple
of the things that people should know
that maybe they don't fully grasp or
something like that ya know I I think
that the biggest thing is a lot of
people think that they're anti-gun but
they're not they're really not they are
anti you having a gun because they don't
trust themselves and because they don't
trust themselves and they don't have
confidence and their ability to handle
it they project that onto other
individuals I always tell people if
you're anti-gun then you really don't
believe and you I mean you shouldn't
believe in calling the police to come
with their guns if you have a need where
firepower is required as a solution
you shouldn't hire private security if
you're anti-gun and I think that the
idea of well I'm okay with guns so long
as you know private security has them or
police have them and there was a guy who
actually suppose a couple of weeks ago
who on Twitter was telling me oh yeah I
work for the firm that you know moms
demand hires whenever they have events
and I've had moms demand and Everytown
confirm this to me separately from this
but you're hiring private security for
you but you don't want other individuals
to have that access I don't want to
outsource the carrying of my firearm and
that seems really classist if we're to
have a discussion about legitimate class
warfare I would think the idea that only
people wealthy enough to hire private
security to protect them that is
incredibly classist because not
everybody has Bloomberg money and not
everybody is in that position and so if
you're truly anti-gun then you would
believe that for police and military and
everything else it's it's not a little
bit of a position it's
that's one of the the areas that I think
is either/or and there are very few
areas where there really isn't a lot of
nuance I think that an abridgment of a
natural right is a denial of a right so
that would be like that would be the
first thing and the second thing is that
we've always had firearms and we have
more laws now than we ever had and we
have seen only in terms of youths acting
out in ways where they shouldn't and
accessing firearms I think that we are
ignoring a really serious problem in our
society with younger people with young
males particularly and I know you've
talked about this before on your program
a lot of people have discussed this
Norton Peterson has talked about this
this is not getting enough attention and
I'm a boy mom and I can see how easy it
is for young men to go off the rails and
young women can too but there's
something different with young men and
it's really easy for them to go off the
rails and it's almost we are in a
society that is - in my opinion is
hostile towards young men and all young
men and then it gets into varying
degrees of severity depending on
different boxes checked and there all of
that is is just making a kindling for
this problem and until we deal with that
we're always going to have these
problems but you're not going to solve
it by punishing law-abiding people who
are not the fuel for this problem and
then I guess the last thing all of the
laws that people keep saying that we
need we we have I mean every single
thing that was the one I really wanted
you hit yeah every single day I see
somebody propose something and they're
like oh well we should know crazy people
that can buy guns oh okay well you can
have someone committed or you can you
know request there's a whole way to go
about this that preserves due process
and protects innocent people the red
flag wah terrifies me and because it's a
removal of due process red flag laws
aren't even about guns red flag laws are
a complete removal of due process
guns are a variable in this situation
and when people realize that that a
firearm is a variable and when
you set this precedent of completely
obliterating someone's ability to have
that protection of due process you are
going to be able to accuse people and
convict them before a trial on any
number of things this isn't just about
guns think of an it think of an issue
and that to me is a terrifying beginning
to full that's that's a terrifying
concept and the fact that some are so
incredibly lackadaisical about it
they're willing to under to remove that
that pin of of our republic just to what
because they think they're gonna cancel
out Second Amendment that's that's a
horrible way to do it do you think that
the the real tough part is well you got
to explain some truth okay so that
that's tough but the left generally is
much better at the bumper sticker
answers and that is usually what people
who aren't really thinking wanna swallow
I mean the easiest version of this is
when I go to my local supermarket there
is a sign on the outside and has a gun
and it's crossed out and says this is a
gun-free zone and if you're an average
lefty I think you walk in there and
you're like you feel good you're like oh
well there'll be no guns in here that's
fantastic and of course all you have to
do like most things unfortunately that
come out of the left these days think
about it for about 6 to 8 seconds and
usually what you'll find is oh you know
the bad guys they probably don't pay
attention to the stickers but but to do
what you just did there is takes a lot
more time takes more attention takes
more work and knowledge rather than
here's a sticker on the door I feel good
about it to you yeah well and the
stickers don't create this like
invisible force field like that's that
Star Trek technology does not yet exist
in our world or maybe it does and we
just don't know maybe that's what those
UFO videos are about but we should
prevent bad guys from coming into the
area you know they're not going to show
up illegally in possession of a firearm
and I hate the phrase illegal guns it's
always illegal possession they're not
gonna show up with an illegally possess
gonna go you know what I was gonna go in
here and do some really shady stuff but
this sticker it's thicker thicker it
that doesn't it yeah that does this
never happened and John Lott who
is a walking encyclopedia he's done a
lot of research on this and I think what
is it like the vast majority of mass
casualty incidents these mass shootings
that have taken place from the period of
1953 till the current time have been in
gun-free zones and a lot of these
gun-free zones they don't even have
right they don't even have armed
security to protect that or at least try
to protect the people that they allow to
come in so that that is like Linus's
blanket right it's a safety blanket this
idea of a gun free anything and why
don't you just put a sign out that says
crime free where does some crime
acceptable to you just a crime-free zone
sticker that this is it's never work we
we live in a reality where this is what
I think freedom scares some freedom
scares people some people
cannot handle freedom because they don't
I think Trust themselves and they don't
trust other people and there are going
to be people that are going to abuse
their freedom and even after they have
been caught and they have faced justice
and they have been punished they're
still going to reoffended they're still
going to choose to do bad things with
their free will and the you will you're
never going to be able to legislate evil
away because you cannot legislate that
away in each individual and the the
solution isn't to remove people's
ability to defend themselves the
solution is to make criminals afraid
with more severe penalties instead of I
mean I can sit here and talk to you
about our justice system on and on and
on because I think we have a massive
problem and we have too many felonies
and you know some of the nonviolent it
just you know goes on and on but for the
serious offenders there need to be
penalties that really are adequate
deterrence and and allow a quit
punishing the law-abiding for what these
people choose to freely do and I always
tell people you know they're no such
thing as loopholes it's like if someone
is caught driving under the influence
they have their license suspended and
they continue going in it in and driving
a vehicle they get caught that's not a
loophole they're breaking the law that's
a criminal act
so these loopholes that people keep
talking about there's criminal acts and
non criminal acts there's no nuance
there the ATF has things covered to the
point of being over covered so there's
there's a criminal act and then there's
a non criminal act
there's no loophole but we always hear
about the gun show loophole I know the
gun show loophole because you know you
always have gang members day of going
out there and buying super expensive
collectors guns and then going out and
committing all of these crimes with
collectors items and even that is even
even private sales are regulated to a
point and the penalty on that is
incredibly high but that's not how I
mean gangbangers they've done surveys on
this they're people who are committing
crimes are getting this off the black
market and if you think you're gonna
eradicate the black market I mean look
how well the war on drugs has gone you
think that this is gonna be any
different I mean it's the same thing
different variable
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversation about the gun
debate instead of non-stop yelling check
out our gun debate playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell